the case of autistic ben oliver who
admitted killing his grandfather in a
stabbing frenzy is especially grim and
complex
you selected a knife from the kitchen
and you went to your grandfather's room
you then cut his throat repeatedly with
severe force
you stabbed his mouth so that he could
not cry out
in sentencing him the judge had to
balance truth and fairness and for the
first time live on television i then
have to turn to consider aggravating
factors
they are four
one the vulnerability of your bed-bound
elderly grandfather
two the physical suffering inflicted
upon him
three your previous offending and four
the fact that you were on license
however
there is considerable additional
mitigation in relation to your
upbringing your experiences as a child
and the fact that other members of your
family to your knowledge wanted and on
two occasions set out to kill your
grandfather due to the unproven
allegations made against him
or further significance is your recent
discovery that he had hurt your beloved
grandmother
oliver said the judge had admitted his
guilt and shown remorse but the killing
was ferocious and he was a danger to the
public the sentence i pass upon you is
therefore one of life imprisonment with
a minimum term of ten years and eight
months
such live broadcasts from inside
criminal courts will become the norm but
limited strictly to the judge the
sentence and the judge's explanation for
the punishment
cameras are being allowed in after a
long campaign by the main tv news
broadcasters
it is important with something like
sentencing remarks if there's a public
interest in
understanding why a particular sentence
was passed
that people have the opportunity to see
all the things that a judge has to think
about
it was this snatched photograph of wife
killer dr krippen in the old bailey dock
in 1910 that led to a ban on cameras in
english and welsh courts
the courts here still lag behind the
judicial systems in some other countries
notably the united states but there's
little appetite to go any further than
focusing cameras on judges and their
sentencing
no one is seriously suggesting uk courts
go down this road
[Music]
for the moment
martin brunt sky news of the old bailey